okay here we are back and the questions
for the panel April Ryan what are your
thoughts on the Howard University
protesters who shouted down James Comey
I don't know about this well first of
all the Howard University students are
very upset that James Comey will now
have this position for a year he's given
the money back to the school but
provision he's gonna be kind of like a
fellow oh he's over top of this this
it's policy governance and Howard
universe Howard University they brought
him in he turned away other colleges and
took this position Howard Howard
students are very upset I thought it
would be more so about the Hillary
election in his part in those remaining
days like the eleven days or so prior to
the election and it wasn't it was mostly
about the history of the FBI in the
black community now the kids have the
right freedom of speech and freedom of
expression they had a right to protest
but the president of Howard University
says call me no matter what we'll be
there for the year but it's interesting
finding out about James Comey and I
found this out through the president of
Howard president Wayne Frederick
he said that James call me whenever he
brings someone when he used to be FBI
director whenever he would bring someone
in he would make them look through the
records the FBI records of dr. Martin
Luther King jr. to show how the
department overreached and he would make
them go to the King memorial it's
interesting it's interesting this done
and he did a bad thing but he's not a
bad guy he's doing six well that's
debatable but he's doing six speeches I
think Tommy's a bad guy um I think it's
yet to be surprised I think we've
brought the verdicts is still out on
coming yeah come on man I think Howard
students are right in that there has
been no friend of the african-american
well he's trying to speak though the
whole point is is he supposed to be
doing these six speeches and they're
basically gonna be about police reform
and criminal justice reform as April
said that was what the first speech is
about and I think it's supposed to be a
series they were chanting the chant that
I found most poignant was a lot of them
chanting commis not my homie
but he thinks he's down yes he does okay
well Hawken do you think that storm
ravaged places like Puerto Rico can be
rebuilt to withstand future extreme
weather events that's a good question I
mean some of these places you know
extreme weather events the ones we just
had are the ones we're gonna have
intended right funny what if they become
uninhabitable that could possibly happen
it can it actually can then the thing is
with global warming is that even if we
stopped emissions today warming is
locked in for the next 20 30 years it's
locked and loaded and the instability
that we're seeing it should be called
global warming it should be called
climatic instability or volatility
because what you're getting is much more
rain much powerful when moma powerful
winds are getting more severe droughts
British Columbia had the biggest fire
season ever in history we had the third
biggest in California all right that's
why our season hasn't even started and
it started yeah it's the preseason like
two billion dollars I that's a really
good question because the old there's
only two rain forests in in the United
States
now there's only one the whole rain
forests are Puerto Rico was destroyed so
and that's just a cat5 you say just a
cat5 but I mean cat6 is coming oh right
I mean that's writ large and the thing
is it's it should be about pattern
recognition which is you can't say it's
due to global warming you can't say that
but you do know that warmer water is
going to intensify whatever happens and
we know that ninety percent of all the
warming that's occurred since industrial
age ninety percent goes into the water
not the land the water so yeah Al Gore
predicted this yes he did and the
Internet
would you agree that he invented it
would you he did not say he invented yes
he did he did not say those words are
you parroting the Republican no I was
there I know I look young but I was
there
[Applause]
remember he believes that he was one of
the people who created the Internet well
that's created but he was very
instrumental having and he should never
have laughed at him saying you know
that's the mistake the Democrats make
they don't back up what they say and
when that when the Republicans were
saying oh you're a liar he's okay you
know what you got me of a liar don't
laugh at myself instead of Jimmy yeah
did you know Louis is a vile Gore
because he's just a wonderful guy but I
think the world is tired of hear hearing
from privileged white men about
disasters they're gonna come in the
future Brown doesn't matter I just
thought why does everything have to be
that what it really I'm a white man I
can't talk about global warming cuz I
believe what should I [ __ ] do yeah I
just send an apology to Kendrick Lamar
tonight
sorry darker revelations its privilege
is people who are well-to-do sent a
million errors telling the world it's
getting bad it's gonna get worse it's a
welcome mat reason how many low-income
black people in the Ninth Ward you see
what's happening in the Virgin Islands
you see what's happening and what are we
go people who live on the water people
who are in these communities tend to be
those the least of these so I mean
people don't and I hate to say this but
this is the way societies they don't
listen to us it took a former vice
president to stand up and speak and he
haven't received a Nobel Prize and no
and he created that great documentary
and people are not listening and now he
was like Chicken Little the sky is
falling the sky is falling it is falling
now but they falsehood that there is no
climate change and it's not caused by
factories and cars of course was put out
my privileged white people in the form
of the Koch brothers and the Republican
Party who put out this fantasy and
convinced that worked that convince a
lot of people so you know if if
privileged white people can make that
untruth be widely believed why can't be
alright tom morello what is your
relationship with Ted Nugent we're
friends we're friends yeah yeah yeah I
mean it's great you know I get [ __ ] for
being friends with right-wingers too and
it'd have to have friends yeah and we
overlap as well we're big advocates of
the First Amendment we're family man we
enjoy rock and roll me yes and there are
things that you know things we differ on
occasionally you know when Ted says
something that fires up the racist
element of his base I'll shoot him I
shoot him a text and say back off then
just shoot him ya know I'm trying to get
him on the show again we just have them
on the old show a lot you know and yeah
okay good
Kurt do you think the militarization of
the police force is another symptom of
living in fantasy land well I do and it
happened without us even noticing and
and what I discovered when in the course
of my research is that it it started a
course right here in Los Angeles the
SWAT team that Daryl gates wanted to
start and created on the universal back
lot yes that that's where they trained
and then there was the Aaron Spelling
show SWAT which came out that is the key
thing that convinced dozens and then
hundreds of cities around America to
need their to create their SWAT team
whatever we see a TV that is where
reality so it can work for good like
with gay marriage yes you know Will and
Grace I see back on the air but I mean
we will in great it a lot to change how
people we saw Trump on TV we saw Trump
that is I don't know if you're being
facetious but for the the jaded
Washington types who think um he's a bad
person Donald John Trump had never been
on the apprentice he would never been
prised exactly we you know I never saw
The Apprentice you did
[Laughter]
you think that's crazy that I never saw
the no no I mean when it first 25
million people a week watch that show do
I have to watch no you don't have to
watch surprise 25 million people's a lot
here's a crazy but I never saw Dancing
with the Stars
you know we on the coast we turned our
nose up The Apprentice that stupid show
and a lot of people in America saw a guy
who was you know in a position of
authority he fired people he was in
charge in the book and it turned out you
know he didn't even do all that he just
came in read his lines like any other
actor like Ronald Reagan I gotta say
it's the White House apprentice now yeah
nobody ever says why did you hire all
these idiots to begin with he's like I
fired him yeah you shouldn't hired him
in the first place I gotta say I was a
little disappointed with this show
tonight only because we didn't get a
chance to have a broader conversation
about Hugh Hefner and go ahead just well
just say I know what I heard that he had
passed away you know I thought I kind of
reached for a tissue and then I reached
for a few more than I thought
[Applause]
just think about the fact that in the
last couple weeks we've lost you after
and Rolling Stones being sold I would
contend that if you think about what
shaped modern culture and there's a lot
of stuff that Kurt writes about it in
his book those two institutions Playboy
and Rolling Stone had as much effect on
shaping the culture post 60s culture as
any two institutions in America and and
and now Kepner is dead and yawen are
selling off Rolling Stone it's an
interesting moment that those two are
kind of I would say even more Playboy
because it was well I mean it does not
control culture the drug culture the
rock that exists I mean they just sex
existed too but before a Playboy not in
a magazine like that no and not a not
mainstream not mainstream he was a
wizard think of this I mean you know
yeah he helped
people reach their potential and
[Laughter]
a lot of people learn how to read but
then there's this real situation and
just hold on from it before you jump me
this is real situation you know I don't
like the fact that women are portrayed
as objects we're more than TNA but but
when when I dug deeper he really was a
great man when it came to issues of
civil rights he was on the cutting edge
exactly and you know sometimes you have
to say hmm all right but for the greater
good
Trump is an inheritor of part of that
playboy mantle this is absolutely his
bob his his fear of women the kind of
the object if ocation of women that's
part of the that's part of one big piece
he doesn't like women I think it's all
wound up together it was sad well maybe
at the end at the end was that but but
so if you just look at a naked woman
that's objectifying
okay no no when you look at a woman and
all you see is what God gave her and not
see her for a woman that's going out
there knocking down the barriers and
walls trying to make a living a woman
who's got a mind who's who's working
hard to change things that are going on
really wait to see everything and
everybody you don't he just got a box of
Kleenex
it's not a bad thing and it's actually a
necessary thing and a helpful thing it
is healthy it is healthy oh absolutely
and
[Applause]
[Applause]